[Music]  Tiffany Haddish claims she saw a whole  new side of Beyonce at a jay-z concert  after-party apparently the lemonade star  is territorial when it comes to her  husband in a preview for TV ones new  series uncensored the girls trip star  recalls the day she met queen bee and  witnessed it firsthand so I got to be  Beyonce and then I went I was talking to  jay-z right I was [ __ ] the jay-z for  a little bit and it was another actress  that she touches his chest and Beyonce  came walking up the her demeanor her  body said when she walked up on it was  like the comedian stayed tight lipped  about which actress got too close to the  family feud rapper if then she started  talking to that actress and some other  stuff happened rival but Haddish did  leave the party with good memories and  this priceless selfie with Dione say